sylvia jeanjacquot pendant les 18 mois
durant lesquels vous avez partagé la
cavale de jacques mesrine
j'allais au cinéma et dans les plus
grands restaurants mais ce que vous
allez dans des boîtes de nuit à paris
non mais à londres en sicile en italie
partout luxembourg une forme mais papa
part et pourquoi pas pareil dans ce cas
paris c'était trop dangereux
ah bon ils allaient au cinéma avec vous
sur les champs elysées dans les
restaurants bars les restaurants se
promener partout sauf en discothèque à
l'espérer pour bayer des descentes de
flics ont les femmes c'est un peu gênant
d'un rapport à vous a beaucoup de choses
par rapport à nous donc valait mieux
éviter quand même alors mairie avait
publié un bouquin il s'appelait
l'instinct de mort vous en publiant il
s'appelle l'instinct de vie
extraordinaire parce que ça se lit comme
on dit bêtement comme un rebond le pire
c'est que c'est vrai et puis en plus
l'histoire est réellement arrivé dans
l'histoire commence clignancourt porte
de clignancourt le 2 novembre 79
vous êtes avec mérine dans une bmw d'un
seul coup il ya un camion bâché à rennes
devant roux ou la base se relève il ya
quatre policiers qui font feu sur mairie
n'est aussi sûr mon sens pourquoi sur
nous je ne sais pas on n'a jamais su ce
que c'était pour éviter ce genre de
choses pour qu'il reste un témoin
quelqu'un pour dire ce qui s'était passé
je veux dire après on a quand même tiré
au mas tire une balle dans la tête juste
au moment où se tourner la tâche d'huile
en attente et quand même de m'achever
une fois que tout était terminé jour
d'avoir géré jacquement donc caniche
aimons vraiment la sortie nous rentrer
la voiture
qu'est-ce qui vous aviez qualcomm comme
blessure mais partout où je vais la tête
explosée où je suis bordelais gauche je
vais je n'ai plus de poigne et je vous
massez une greffe osseuse rad est en
danger un pompage utilise son nom chez
les l'artère claquer la veine minérale
claque et donc on a fait un pontage en
fait on voulait me tuer la tap le mans
probablement parce que j'ai deux déjà
vendues ibm c'était très très large
comme ça ouais on est est resté comme ça
les fauteuils sont très larges
il était à 4 mètres devant lui quatre
tireurs d'élite c'est quand même
d'autant plus qu'après quand tout était
terminé
wen est arrivé de mon côté que matière
une balle en plus à prendre après vente
et à la tête
alors ça c'est le début du lit qu'après
alors il ya un flash back on voit votre
rencontre vous travaillez dans un bar à
pigalle en cause elle était amenée à
travailler dans ce bar à pigalle
c'est la première fois que je mettais
les pieds j'ai travaillé dans différents
bars dans paris est bon à l'époque qui
avait quelques problèmes d'internet
d'ariane et comme je trouve une chercher
du travail ne trouvaient pas et la mitis
malik sens humain même en pensée
marienval et jausiers quoi barnett barma
et un jour vous avez vu arriver jacques
mesrine qui était en cavale qui venait
de ces vallées de la santé qui étaient
déguisées savais pas qui c'était la
panique
1 c'était le coup de foudre tout de
suite des constats leurs deux premiers
tout de suite j'avais su que c'était lui
l'homme de votre vie cette attitude tout
de suite dont il ya très rapidement
qu'est ce qui vous a dit quand il vous
est vu comme ça la première fois
derrière le bar au comptant et à rien il
m'a dit bonjour et je demandais ce qu'il
prenait et lui ont offert un verre ouais
voilà ça commence l'histoire sapin c'est
incroyable vous demande de foot ou vos
affaires en laye en l'air ne rien garder
il veut nous amener en italie et alors
là il ya plein de celles qui sont comme
un film de belmondo pour elle c'est à
dire qu'à un moment vous arrivez à la
frontière italienne
il ya un embouteillage à la douane et il
fait là il fait la circulation il ya un
camion un gros camion qui s'est renversé
du bus tout passage oui bien que la
circulation et ça il est forte il a fait
reculer tout voiture voilà toujours avec
vos casquettes sur la tête en plus une
autre fois l'aéroport il ya sa photo
avec marc est recherché ce mec-là bros
elles toutes les photos de lui et tous
les déguisements imaginables vous aviez
peur quand vous passez la douane comme
ça avait pu non un non pas du tout
une fois vous êtes allé faire une
affiche avec marc et wang xi e siècle
après la mienne est la sienne de calais
loué une maison à j'ai un brigadier en
retraite après ça fait quand il a voulu
acheter l'appartement
c'est bizarre comme cette idée doit
absolument acheter un appartement parce
qu'une fois qu'ils avaient l'argent de
la rançon le lièvre
vous auriez pu partir on devait partir
en partie 2 à 9 ans ouais ont quitté la
france aux partis politiques de lescar
ou tousser le poids des yeux les lèvres
puis pour vous
bonne chance pour prochain ennemi public
numéro 1 à compter de ou comment il
voulait se marier avec dont ils
voulaient braquer sa faire braquer par
ses amis la mairie du viiie
arrondissement et il nous marier sous la
force avec ses calibres cody doucette
vous pouvez vous soyez marié par un
panel estime l'abbesse n'ouvre énoncer
des baptêmes se dire que ça pouvait être
que sous la menace de ses rivales vert
voilà c'est très étonnant et en jean
veste et parce qu'après ça l'est parce
que les parents puisque est très
étonnant dans votre bouquin c'est que
c'est raconter effectivement ça fait
peut-être un teint comme ça ça fait très
avons plus aux gendarmes et voleurs quoi
quand il parle de le lièvre il dit on va
kidnapper le fils qu après midi en
ballon mais le dernier mot radio paiera
pas la rançon
ouais encore la fidh appelle vieux parti
l'a dit oui c'est ce qu'il a fait alors
on a comparé mérine
cartouche à manderen robin des bois en
fait quand on lit enfin quand on sait
qu'il était quand même quand on lit
votre bouquin quand même il a pas que ce
côté-là redresseur de torts il a quand
même un côté un peu beau quand
jean-claude passe ses journées à
regarder la télé en critiquant plus tard
en séchant de dîner à la maison de
rester dans kanaté et de révéler sa télé
n'importe quoi pourvu que ce soit à la
télé qui marche en fait on s'aperçoit
que l'ennemi public numéro 1 était assez
petit bourgeois finalement oui mais
c'est excellent
alors il ya des crises comme ça commence
à spéculation crise les connaissez
connaître mais c'est terrible mais c'est
vraiment en colère
par exemple il ya quelque chose à la
télé on est trop petit fourneau l'appel
mesrine au lieu des russes allure alors
qu'elle est là aujourd'hui bleus mange
ou alors tant pis si on dit hamon qui
n'est pas correct sur lui avec pique
nique aux lèvres et rentable après le
type de la télé nation je pourrais moi
il veut tuer le mec de la télé pas le
tuer mon feeling crise il est bon on
était très en colère et bouvard que
s'ils voulaient lui faire à philippe
bouvard parce qu'ils n'en votre livre
sans arrêt je vous dit qu'il veut donner
une raclée à philippe bouvard
mais il avait dit s'il avait un petit
moment à perdre il est en fibres et une
dans le crâne en moto vite fait en moto
vite fait oui pourquoi parce qu'ils
n'aimaient pas le petit théâtre de
bouvard
parce que je crois qu'avant que jacques
fevad de la santé dit encore détenus les
cris des saletés sur lui
n'était pas content il ya des choses
qu'on a retrouvé des bandes magnétiques
on a retrouvé rue belliard après après
la mairie
non pendant la fouille et de studio
après la mort de jacques où vous avez
dire ses complices quand même quand il
dit je vais aller voir le juge petit
pour lui pour lui donner une leçon vous
dit tu as raison mon poussin peut être
méchant pour la ddiss a quand même plein
vent temps des fêtes
vous l'avez entendu la galerie je peux
vous lavez coupez / sipa de qu'à
l'époque elle est passée devant la
fondatrice de cette tempête
vous avez vraiment des ça c'est pas très
bien grave
ce devront ils arrivent à l'epal tuer
ils allaient les corrections et dû
prendre ces dossiers vous pensez
vraiment qu'il voulais pas le tuer alors
on apprend dans votive comment mérine
s'est fait attraper quoi c'est
l'histoire de l'air qui est digne d'un
roman policier pour pour inventer ça je
veux dire faut c'est à dire que lui en
fait il avait 1h14
la police parle d'une r5 mon copain qui
avaient porté leur cas peut garder l'air
14,5 avaient acheté leur cavale après il
la passa charlie bauer voilà un qui
gardèrent 14 la police parle de r5 et
lui se met à parler de l'ère sarkozy
voilà donc la police se rend compte que
s'il parle lui de r5 c'est qu'ils
avaient gardé leurs 14 ou 15 ans aline
avec garde et c'est comme ça qui suit
attrapé ça a déjà été dit ça ou c'est la
première fois qu'on le dit c'est parce
qu'on semble que c'est la première fois
pour lui selon la fage dans un élément
parce que comme j'ai jamais vu la presse
moi je n'ai jamais parlé de ce que les
prix compte aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient
filé charlie bauer on savait pas
l'histoire de la f1 quemener la voiture
était déclarée et donc ils sont remontés
par sa part plein de choses lance un bon
aussi paraît-il que lui charlie il avait
été balancé par quelqu'un qui avait un
ami dans la peau m j'avais été acquitté
j'ai passé deux ans en prison j'ai été
acquitté ce qui vous avait porté plainte
parce qu'en fait ils étaient pas les
flics étaient par légitime défense quand
non non pas du tout n'est pas écrit non
donc il y avait déjà pas vraiment de
raison de tirer sur lui encore moins sur
vous donc vous avez commencé par porter
plainte
oui ça ne l'était quitté est-ce que ça a
été un deal entre entre votre avocat et
la justice en disant nous en retire
notre plainte et puis on se dira vosges
été acquitté support that is the
prostate duré huit jours j'ai été
acquitté
j'avais plusieurs reculs passion dorcel
j'ai eu un non lieu
oui mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
plaine parce que la plainte geste on a
toujours essayé de faire avec mes
proches et amis qu'il fallait pour achat
froid vous c'est pas possible
non parce qu'ils disent que c'était le
doyen des juges d'instruction j'avais vu
que d'après le bleu le procès verbal du
commissaire broussard ganic remili délit
à ben non alors donc ena il arrêtait là
c'est tout le commissaire broussard vie
nous sommes descendu du camion nous
avons encerclé la voiture nous avons
compté jusqu'à 3 nous avons sucrier
police ou les mains rendez-vous et
croyant voir voilà enfin voilà procès
verbal savez que c'est pas vrai ah oui
c'est vrai j'avais qu'ils ont tiré
directement directement tiré comme un
lapin
oui c'est moi l'arrivée cqt jean liquide
et rémy quitté gilson milla combien pour
la voir ils étaient 95 était debout
c'était comme ça le corps fusils pointés
sur nous
et la chose en bois comme sa honda il
était de gauche en france et ils le
savent et lucas se faire attraper
oui mais je veux dire bon il ya tous il
ya toujours un joli rebond il savait que
si on le prenait on lui mettre une balle
dans la tête le menu des oui mais je
veux dire il ya qu'il gardait quand même
toujours l'espoir parce que je veux dire
il avait prévu l'appartement cas où la
chirurgie esthétique je veux dire que
tout était prévu de dire bon même si ça
les feuilles art déco même espoir de
pouvoir partir et de passer au travers
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que ça
arrive juste au moment où vous alliez
partir c'est comme dans les films
alors il ya un fait qui est fou c'est
qu'on vous a rendu les bijoux qui
avaient été achetés qui vous a été
offert par par jacques avec mes
compagnons de l'art ensemble veillesse
comment ça se fait c'est moi qui vous ai
fait acheter la star en france faisait
bon moi il m'a offert des bijoux je n'ai
pas regardé avec quoi vous les avez eue
après ses bijoux
oui et le lien vous a pas de problème
mais moi je ne sais pas avec quoi chacun
sait les bijoux ouais je ne sais pas si
c'est l'argent de la réponse et ça l'est
pas mais identiques ce qui est dingue si
vous n'avez pas de remords pas de
regrets pas de repentir
non non à l'ue qui n'ont plus rien on
fait quoi maintenant
maintenant sur la cession travailler et
l'acteur en ce moment ce n'était pas une
amie qui vient
d'ouvrir un bar ya deux mois et pour
l'instant mon quand même avec personne
je la dépanne en attendant vous tenez un
bar pour le moment nous certains bâches
des fans une amie s'agit barmaid chez
une amie csel poindre un bas et la sage
la dépanne en ce moment elle a ouvert il
ya deux mois j'ai pu d'histoire avec la
police la non c'était à refaire vous
referiez la même chose quand même
toujours dit leur valait la peine
vous allez at-elle d'être connue jeudi
aux mêmes sachant les suites se dire oui
et non je regrette pas même si
maintenant je puis bang handicapés de
trop près tout ce qu'ont vu le choix
grande panique
c'est un bruit ces boules j'ai bien beau
il en valait vraiment la peine c'est
quand même quelqu'un lozère je suis
désolé mais en dehors d'être ennemi
public numéro 1 le personnage dans la
vie c'est quelqu'un de bien